[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه ان تزويد الغرب الاكياس
بالدبابات سيؤدي الى دفع المواجهه بين
روسيا والغرب الى مستوى جديد واضافت في
مؤتمر صحفي موسكو ان اي سلاح غربيا ينتمي
به المطاف في اوكرانيا سيصبح هدفا مشروعا
للقوات الروسيه
اينشتاين الامريكيه في المانيا عقدت
الجلسه الثامنه لمجموعه الاتصال بشان
مساعده العسكريه لاوكرانيا نتائج هذا
الاجتماع تشهد على عدم تحلي الغرب
بالمسؤوليه اطلاقا ورغبتهم في تصعيد
الصراع اكد دول النيتو انها ستزيد اندادا
اكياس بلاسلحه الهجوميه الثقيله الحديثه
اؤكد ان اي سلاح غربي
اوكرانيا سيصبح هدفا مشروعا لقواتنا
الامدادات بالدبابات لن تغير الوضع نظام
اكياس لكنها تذهب بالدول الغربيه الى
مستوى جديد من المواجهه مع بلدنا